wachs thüringen zu viel
die geplante aufhebung der korona
beschränkungen löst eine breite
diskussion aus ende des ramadan wegen
corona feiern muslime in deutschland das
traditionelle zuckerfest mit vielen
einschränkungen und wasserwerfer und
tränengas die polizei in hongkong geht
massiv gegen demonstranten vor
sie protestieren gegen ein neues
sicherheitsgesetz
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen schön dass sie dabei sind
es sei ein klarer fehler und verfrüht
kritisieren die einen die anderen
applaudieren bodo ramelow der
ministerpräsident thüringens will als
erster vom 6 juni an die landesweiten
corona beschränkungen aufheben weil es
in den landkreisen zum teil kaum mehr
neuinfektionen gibt künftig sollen im
notfall die einzelnen kreise maßnahmen
verhängen
an seinem stern berichtet fast
unbeschwert trotz virus krise das geht
schon heute zumindest bei vielen in
thüringen etwa wo schon sehr bald schon
in zwei wochen tatsächlich alle
generellen corona regeln fallen könnten
großes gesprächsthema natürlich heute in
erfurt
ich finde es mutig nicht zu sagen
riskant ich bin ein junger gesunder
mensch muss ja auch immer an die alten
denken die zur risikogruppe gehören
ich würde sagen mit gemischten gefühlen
mir macht die wirtschaft mehr sorgen
dass mit corona momentan keine verbote
mehr nur noch gebote das ist bodo
ramelow plan
ein vorschlag der weit geht und der für
heftigen streit sorgt wir verlassen uns
stark auf masken und auf abstand halten
gerade das jetzt zur disposition zu
stellen gerade das aufzuheben dass das
jeder machen kann wie er will
das ist brandgefährlich wir sind
entsetzt darüber dass thüringen jetzt
auf elementarste schutzmaßnahmen
verzichten möchte es ist eine maßnahme
die zur unzeit kommt und die der
situation auch nicht angemessen ist
ramelow koalitionspartner von der
thüringer spd wenig begeistert über das
verfahren
unser ministerpräsident hat in der
vergangenheit immer mal wieder
vorschläge gemacht und entscheidungen
getroffen ohne sie mit seiner partei
abzustimmen oder mit dem
koalitionspartner von daher ein wenig
rita zion irritationen und mehr als
ungewöhnliche allianzen ramelow von der
linkspartei bekommt unterstützung von
der fdp
und wir wollen dass regional
differenziert wird das muss intelligent
und konsequent mit vorsicht und
rücksicht
gemacht werden deshalb ist es richtig
dort wo es geringe infektionszahlen gibt
etwas mehr freiheit zu erlauben was
wieder erlauben was noch nicht die suche
nach dem richtigen weg raus aus der
virus krise bleibt umstritten
bundesweit ist die zahl der täglichen
neuinfektionen seit tagen ziemlich
stabil
so kommen im durchschnitt der
vergangenen sieben tage derzeit täglich
600 ansteckungen hinzu seit ausbruch der
pandemie wurden mehr als 180.000
infizierte registriert davon gelten rund
160.000 als genesen 8283 menschen sind
in verbindung mit cupid 19 gestorben
wie fragil die lage ist zeigt die
gruppen ansteckung in hessen bei einem
optischen gottesdienst in frankfurt vor
rund zwei wochen haben sich deutlich
mehr menschen infiziert als angenommen
der hessische gesundheitsminister klose
spricht von 107 infizierten gestern war
noch die rede von 40 religiöse feiern in
zeiten von corona für muslime auf der
ganzen welt geht der fastenmonat ramadan
zu ende
währenddessen verzichteten die gläubigen
tagsüber auf essen trinken rauchen und
sex
in deutschland leben etwa 4,7 millionen
muslime auch für sie ist das
fastenbrechen das zuckerfest einer der
wichtigsten religiösen feiertage dieses
jahr eben etwas anders als sonst an ahnt
sie haben wochenlang verzichtet in
diesem jahr sogar auf die gemeinschaft
nun zum ende des ramadan strömen bremens
muslime wieder in die moscheen
doch wegen der chor ohne regeln findet
längst nicht alle einen platz breiten
ihre teppiche kurzerhand davor aus wie
sie sehen laufen hier über 50 ordner rum
wir gucken uns schon darauf dass die
menschen
abstände halten dass sie soziale distanz
eingehalten wird das halt die menschen
mit ihren eigenen gebetsteppiche hier
kommen andrang mit abstand auch gestern
bei sonnenuntergang in den restaurants
nachdem viele muslime abend für abend zu
hause essen mussten
das abendliche beisammensein mit
freunden oder fällt anderen familien ist
ein wichtiger teil im ramadan und das
ist
es ist schön mal wieder raus zu gehen
mit freunden und dass wir mal erst am
ende des ramadan zusammen den betreiber
freut viele einnahmen sind ihm in den
letzten monaten weggebrochen ebenso wie
den moscheevereinen ramadan ist haupt
spendenzeit normalerweise mögliche hilfe
verspricht nun der bürgermeister im
rahmen der unterstützung ehrenamtlichen
engagement über die sozialen projekte
der religionsgemeinschaften gibt ja auch
gelitten haben wie sie es gesagt haben
unter dem verringerten schwingungen
aufkommen über das unterstützen können
mit dem morgengebet hat nun das
mehrtägige zuckerfest begonnen nach
langer zeit der entbehrung ganz anderes
thema jetzt in israel kein
ministerpräsident war dort so lange an
der macht wie benjamin netanjahu heute
vor einer woche begann der 70-jährige
seine fünfte amtszeit aber netanjahu ist
auch der erste regierungschef der in
seiner amtszeit vor gericht steht seit
heute die vorwürfe betrug untreue und
bestechlichkeit nicola albrecht
berichtet für israels premierminister
eine neue rolle als angeklagter in einem
strafprozess
es sind die ersten bilder aus dem
bezirksgericht in jerusalem
doch bevor die staatsanwaltschaft die
anklageschrift verliest tritt internet
vor die kameras und weist noch einmal
öffentlich alle vorwürfe zurück was
heute vor gericht steht ist der versuch
den willen des volkes zunichte zu machen
es ist der versucht mich und den rechts
konservativen flügel zu stürzen
doch die vorwürfe gegen ihn liegen
schwer betrug untreue bestechlichkeit in
netanja ausfall geht es um
machtmissbrauch beeinflussung der medien
zu seinen gunsten und um zweifelhafte
luxus geschenke im wert von mehr als
100000 euro bei einer rechtskräftigen
verurteilung drohen ihm bis zu zehn
jahre haft erst dann müsste er auch sein
amt als premier niederlegen
es geht um mehr als schuld oder unschuld
eines amtierenden premierministers
dieser prozess wird test- und wegweiser
sein wir zeigen die es um israels
rechtsstaatlichkeit und demokratie am
ende bestellt sein wird welche kräfte
und politischen meinungen sich
durchsetzen werden
hoch lebe der könig von israel
skandieren netanjahus anhänger vor dem
gericht auch sie glauben an eine
verschwörung der sogenannten linken und
medien gegen ihren premier hunderte
netanjahu kritiker demonstrieren zur
gleichen zeit vor dessen residenz in
jerusalem
sie befürchten netanjahu könne durch
eine systematische schwächung des
justizsystems und über
gesetzesänderungen seine verurteilung
schlussendlich verhindern
der amerikanische außenminister nennt es
eine totenglocke für die autonomie
hongkongs mit einem neuen
sicherheitsgesetz will china in hongkong
offenbar endgültig für ruhe sorgen und
treibt die menschen jetzt wieder auf die
straße mit tränengas und wasserwerfern
gegen die polizei gegen pro
demokratische demonstranten vor thomas
konnte die menge flieht das tränengas
kommt beißender weißer nebel auf
hongkongs straßen rückzug mit
regenschirmen trotz corona
beschränkungen sind hunderte
demonstranten unterwegs
es gibt festnahmen verletzte es gibt
immer mehr proteste gegen den einfluss
der chinesischen führung
das sogenannte nationale
sicherheitsgesetz ist nur ein vorwand
für die kommunistische partei die bürger
hongkongs zu unterdrücken
jegliche freiheit wird zugeschnitten die
meinungs- und pressefreiheit
das lassen wir nicht zu wir geben nicht
auf
genauso entschlossen chinas präsident hu
er will das gesetz schnell abnicken
lassen es soll etwa subversive
aktivitäten wie grund geben verhindern
und antichinesische umtriebe beweise
dafür sieht peking auch in diesen
bildern bombenmaterial in hongkong
beschlagnahmt eskalierende gewalt und
terrorismus gefährden die sicherheit
bekräftigte außenminister heute
sie bedrohen die stabilität von hongkong
und das prinzip ein land zwei systeme
genau das aber bedroht pekings langer
arm fürchten die demonstranten die
demokratie verteidigen
darum geht es für sie im tränengas nebel
von hongkong harter schnitt zum sport
fußball bundesliga zwei der drei
sonntagsspiele sind abgepfiffen schalke
verliert daheim 0 zu 3 gegen augsburg
und in mainz gewinnt leipzig mit 5 0 und
rückt auf tabellenplatz drei vor
zur stunde läuft das derby köln gegen
düsseldorf manchmal wachsen menschen
über sich hinaus das bewies ein mädchen
aus indien die 15 jährige hat ihren
gehbehinderten vater mit dem fahrrad aus
der stadt in ihr heimatdorf gefahren
1200 kilometer weit wegen der korona
ausgangssperre konnte der vater nicht
mehr arbeiten keine miete mehr zahlen
züge und busse fuhren nicht der indische
radsport verband hat die achtklässlerin
jetzt zum trainieren ins nationalteam
eingeladen durchhaltevermögen habe sie
ja bewiesen und das übrigens bei
temperaturen um die 40 grad
damit sind wir beim wetter im westen
längerer sonnenschein sonst mehr wolken
und von der oder bis zu den alpen einige
schauer bei lebhaften nordwestwind 14
bis 22 grad und die weiteren aussichten
meist freundlich und wieder da man damit
verabschiede ich mich von ihnen wünschen
noch einen richtig schönen sonntagabend
und möchte ihnen nur noch zwei kollegen
ans herz legen christian sievers um
viertel vor zehn im heute-journal und
jetzt theo koll mit berlin direkt